chris is in salt lake city hi chris how
can we help
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what time i really appreciate your time
so i had a question about paying off uh
upcoming medical bill because we're
expecting our first child
beginning of february and i've spent
hours calling around trying to get the
numbers on that and decide to go with an
hsa plan because it had the lowest max
out of pocket
or worst case scenario my wife and i
saved up money last year to pay off her
student loans
and the amount is probably about a
thousand dollars difference between
paying off the med
medical bill the max out-of-pocket for
the family and
her student loans and so my question is
which one would you pay
and i know that student loan forgiveness
is kind of a hot topic right now and so
i would hate to pay the student loans
and then find out we get
10 000 reimbursed or forgiven
and so right now the student loan is 12
900
the max out of pocket for the family
insurance would be 13
800. and you're going to max it
yes everyone i've talked to said that
i'm going to max out the
for my wife and then for our son we'll
be like
two thousand dollars away and so we were
considering just maxing it out for worst
case scenario but also
my wife wanted to have a surgery get her
tonsils out
i needed a sinus surgery so we figured
this was the year to just
get that taken care of oh and that's all
in the 13.
after the 13 000. usually labor and
delivery is not 13.
okay i call different doctors and
whatnot and asked what they charge for
delivery and add that all up i'm sorry
you have a baby due in february yes
okay well here's the thing the the uh
regardless of the student loan
forgiveness issue that doesn't enter
into the equation for me
because i think it's so unlikely and
it'll be such a long time
before all that occurs that you're not
going to see that relief anytime soon if
you ever do see it
so i want you to pay your student loan
uh and i want you to pay your medical
bills which one would i pay first i pay
the medical bills first they're
immediately due
the student loan has terms to it medical
bills don't have terms
the only reason get people get payments
on medical bills is because they can't
pay the bill
it's due when they send it to you 100
and so you need to pay that bill or
you're in default
and they'll put you on payments but i
don't want you to get into default you
pay the whole bill
and so but right now you're just saving
up money until baby comes we're not
doing debt snowball we're not doing
anything except
living on a budget piling up cash and
when you get
these uh baby comes and these
miscellaneous small surgeries are done
then you um uh
you know you pay your bill pay your
medical bill and then you tear into that
student loan as soon as you can
okay easy enough easy enough
congratulations we appreciate you
congratulations that's awesome man
what a great way to start 2021